well that didn't take too long did it i
had so much fun writing my decade in
review for action anime that i decided
why not do something similar again i'm
glad that you seem to have generally
enjoyed the video and i'm very happy for
the feedback and suggestions i received
however instead of going over to the
next genre i wanted to put a bit of a
twist on this one i've got a strong
feeling that i'll keep going back to
this format soon so i've decided to push
the other genres to the side for now and
focus on a staple of a lot of action
anime fights
you guys love fights and the stats back
that up so for today i'll be going over
what i feel are the best anime fights to
occur in a particular year over the past
decade as usual the decision is going to
be subjective but i'll try to find the
most generalist measure to pick my
favorite fight per year and if i happen
to overlook something don't be afraid to
notify me in the comments section i'll
also limit the winners to one pair
series to keep the entries as diverse as
possible consider this a compliment to
the previous video on best action anime
of the decade as always please hit the
subscribe button to help the channel
grow it doesn't take too long and your
contribution is always greatly
appreciated
2011
as we close the book on a decade of
anime action fights herald the dawn of a
new era 2011 for me will always be known
as the year of stein's gate and madoka
magica as i mentioned in the previous
video the latter in particular is a
perpetual favorite of mine and the
battle between homura and walpurgis
knight feels like a strong contender in
terms of its narrative importance and
how over the top it was in the previous
video the best action anime came down to
fate zero and hunter hunter and they've
got their awesome fights too however i'd
like to talk about how 2011 sets the
bookends for some legacy series that
were pushing strong from the decade
prior alucard finally had his
much-awaited showdown with anderson and
is every bit as intense and violent as
we expect something from helsing to be
still if we look at legacy and narrative
importance i think the few can beat out
my pick for the year ichigo versus aizen
it was a long time coming before power
ichigo and isaiah in his nth evolution
collided in a clash that marked the end
of an era one of the most beloved shonen
of the 2000s it's also a notable fight
in that it functions more as a flex for
ichigo who surpassed whatever evolution
eisen could have for the first time the
smug villain finally found a foe beyond
his comprehension after spending literal
months just trouncing everything thrown
at him yeah i'm aware that bleach as an
anime continued past this arc but for a
lot of fans i mean that was really it
this was the final battle in climax that
they've all been waiting for and we
finally saw aizen defeated after almost
a decade
2012.
remember when i mentioned fate zero a
while ago well the show ran all the way
to 2012 for your information and that's
why my personal favorite fight from the
series qualifies for 2012 and will be
taking the crown rider versus gilgamesh
no i personally find myself leaning more
towards kiritsugu versus kirei what i
like about this fight is the fact that
it's not about the spectacle it's not
about the huge armies or the walls of
swords that you relate to the fate
series it's how down and dirty the two
got and i feel like it encapsulates what
sets fate zero apart compared to the
rest of the franchise 2012's also when
another epic fight gone vs hisoka took
place it's one of the best underdog
fights out there in anime and i hope
that you'll take a look at it
i don't have a lot of honorable mentions
off the top of my head for this year
honestly this year has a lot of good
action shows but few really had that
level of oomph that made them stand out
since 2012 when the sao craze hit town i
guess we can consider the gleam ice
fight here it is pretty damn iconic
after all
2013.
we all know that 2013 is attack on
titan's year in terms of [ __ ] influence
none of the shows this year can compare
to it the female titan arc is an
emotional roller coaster and the aaron
vs female titan fight was a great way to
cap off the series
[Music]
psycho pass also gave us golgarmi vs
makishima it's such an amazingly
choreographed battle and it would be a
shame not to give it the spotlight here
whereas ippo versus sawamura didn't have
quite that same amount of choreography
it more than makes up for it with
intensity and hype and if you're up for
more magical elements and one man army
fight this is the year madara wrecked
the shinobi alliance but
none of those are my winners for this
year that's because this is the year
where madoka rebellion came out and
along with it came a fight that at the
time pushed the limits of action
sequences in an anime feature film
production yes i'm talking about homura
vs mommy
the famed gunfight that people still
remember rebellion for almost a decade
later excellent cinematography helped
push a full fight of momentum shifts
into legendary status and the moment i
saw this fight it was going to make it
to one of these lists someday
2014
if you remember my video on action anime
you'd know that 2014 is also quite the
busy year for action anime lots of big
hitters spread all around the year
giving us a healthy selection starting
off we have noragami's final battle
which feels like a modern take on
rurouni kenshin ark's climax i'm not
fond of how rabo got defeated but the
context of the fight gives it enough
emotional weight for those who are
looking for fate stay night unlimited
blade works in said video i did hold
back on mentioning it due to my
self-imposed sequel clause i considered
it a sequel to fate zero with me
shifting to series clause this time it's
fully legible for a top spot on this
list well the kuzuki fight looks very
inviting but unlimited blade works
wouldn't hit its peak this year so let's
just have it waiting on the back burner
for now agame guar kill also aired this
year apologies to the fans for missing
out on my other video but it's about
time for it to make an appearance here
akame vs gurome is one of my favorite
sibling fights in anime after all as
death versus agame was one epic fight as
well and that's exactly why i feel it
deserves a mention here
as a side note the naruto final arc
rages on through this year giving us one
of its best fights in not just shippuden
but the entire series obito versus
kakashi their fates finally collide in
this climactic battle brilliantly
capping off one of the most intriguing
and captivating backstory feuds in the
franchise that's all because 2014 is
when we got the fame netero vs meru in
battle in hunter hunter if you were to
ask me to pick the best fight from
hunter hunter this would be it
of course i'm not just reducing the
series appeal to just fights but in
terms of a spectacle itself i do find
this one hard to top if i look back at
the series some fights like the famous
one with adult gone come close to the
level of epicness but the appeal from
those fights come from somewhere else
like the context if you're looking at
just choreography and playing anime
brawling along with a dramatic
conclusion netero vs meruem is where
it's at
2015.
as i said in the action anime video this
is the year of one punch man and
rightfully so it steps up to the plate
for what i think is the fight of the
year the battle between saitama and
boros
in terms of the sheer spectacle and the
over-the-top appeal not a lot of fights
from this year come to mind it's also
the climax of what was the year's most
influential anime so it does deserve the
spot in my opinion and it's a shame
because this is also the year when my
favorite battle in the fade stay night
ubw happened archer versus shiro is so
strong thematically the way the fight
turned out as well as the masterful
placement of last stardust creates one
of my favorite moments in 2015. alas i
put this as runner up because fate has
an even better looking and bigger fight
lined up later spoilers i guess dio and
jodaro also had their iconic battle this
year a fight that will send shockwaves
and memes through the jojo universe for
years to come for niche picks i do give
honourable mentions to alfonso versus
leon from garrow and k's misaki vs
saruhiko both are underrated shows that
you might want to check out
2016. 2016 is a landmark year for anime
after its long storied run naruto
finally came to an end and gave us the
final battle that we've all been
clamoring for naruto versus sasuke for
me is the only proper way for the series
to close its book the two now in their
peak form after more than a decade of
history have their destined showdown and
it ended beautifully too with a virtual
tie where sasuke eventually admits
defeat it's not about the physical
battle but the emotional one here guys
my fight for the year goes on in a
similar tangent bitter rivals and
friends turned enemies gintoki and
takasugi had one hell of a battle in
2016. and that's my pick for this year's
best fight
why well personally i felt more
emotional investment in this fight yeah
gintama's not as popular as naruto
generally speaking but in terms of how
the emotions of the fighters got
conveyed in this fight this is just on a
whole nother level it's also not just
the fighters throwing big fireballs or
overpowered plot armor bombs at each
other i'm not sure how popular of an
opinion that is but kintoki vs takasugi
takes the history and big fight feel
that naruto versus sasuke has and
grounds it into a more realistic and
artistic form
if we're just looking at animation
however i'd definitely give the win to
mob dismantling daeru or mob vs koyama
unfortunately the fight just didn't have
the emotional investment or the history
for me to declare it the winner over the
gintama fight oh yeah this year also saw
my hero academia's debut but frankly
none of the early fights are that
impressive relatively speaking but now
closest contender i could think of would
be all white versus no move
2017
however in 2017 my hero academia took it
up a notch giving us its best fight up
until that point midoriya versus
dodoroki i also found dodorogi to be the
more likable rival to midoriya yeah
bakugo has a history and all of that but
as far as fellow heroes whose stories
midoriya likewise plays a big role in
dodoroki is the man i really loved how
his ideologies collide with midoriya and
this fight encapsulates that
black clover also got its start this
year but it's the definition of a late
bloomer at this point of its run it's
mostly meme fodder which i feel is a
huge disservice actually a lot of the
most epic moments and fights in the
series are stowed away in the latter
episodes and arcs so those of you who
are fans of the series will just have to
wait a little longer now okay oh an sao
ordinal scale came out and along with it
came the pinnacle of sao fights the raid
boss battle in the film's climax is the
epic finale we never got for the series
propers einkradak for this year i give
the title to a shonen great that somehow
reinvigorated itself somewhere in this
decade yes dragon ball super takes the
title with its amazing goku vs jiren
fight now i know about you but i would
call this a candidate for the most
intense fight we've covered in the list
so far this is the one with super saiyan
blue and ultra instinct for those who've
been following the series and it pretty
much shows us the heart of the dragon
ball that 90s kids have loved
long drawn-out fights and twists and
turns after every false finish and if i
remember correctly it even crashed the
crunchyroll website now that's something
you don't see often
2018.
let me get this out of the way as
quickly as i can goku versus jiren round
two featuring the iconic perfect form of
ultra instinct took place this year now
i still feel that the first fight
slightly edges out the second one in
terms of the actual fighting and hype
behind him seven deadly sins also had
its blaze of glory here with the
exciting meliodus vs commandments fight
a fitting end before the animation went
to hell and it became meme fodder but i
still wish the next season's got way
more love it feels bad on how they
wasted meliodas versus eskenor with that
travesty of an adaptation
[Applause]
my hero academia also reached what i
feel is a good end point for a chunk of
the story with one for all and all might
clashing after years of build-up the
hype is completely justified here and it
serves as a fitting closure to the world
of my hero academia that we started with
the landscape and the name of the game
completely changed from that point
onward and that episode is worth the
watch even for that fight alone
none of those though won the fight of
the year in 2018. the winner that's the
momoshiki fight boruto may have its
whole slew of criticisms but for a
moment the sasuke and naruto vs
momoshiki fight made me forget about a
lot of those hey i can't help it now can
i see the two legends of the previous
series come together and kick ass once
again brought the kid out in me and i
couldn't help but immerse myself in the
battle even after stepping back and
looking at it from a more objective
perspective the fight does still hold up
it's a joy to watch with how their
powers and chemistry with each other
have developed through time
2019
if i were to talk about 2019 i'd be
talking about a lot of things favorite
fights were plenty and i could spend an
entire day talking about them maybe i
could go for one of mob's season 2
beautifully animated fights well that
time levi gave us a masterclass on how
to pivot a monumental sacrifice into
pure methodical destruction we've also
got the climax of the luffy versus
katakuri fight this year which easily
was one of my favorite fights in one
piece the heavens feel movies are also
screaming around about this time and
they really did the saber versus
berserker fight justice speaking of fate
babylonia still hasn't ended its run at
this point but we already got a very
good fight in gorgon vs ushiwakamaru as
well as the quetzalcoatl fight but
that's not what we're here for now is it
right we all know you're here for the
single most influential fight in anime
history in my opinion which of course is
tanjiro vs rui it pretty much sets the
bar for tv anime fights with how much it
enhanced what was already a goosebump
inducing moment in the manga ufo table
made magic happen and if you're still on
the fence about me calling this one of
the most influential fights in anime
history then let me ask you this
question where else did an anime fight
break the internet so much that it
turned an anime with decent popularity
into the sensation of the year overnight
it's still arguable but in my experience
never had i seen that phenomenon before
demon slayer not an event
not a plot twist but a fight a fight
that was able to catapult its series
into never before seen heights i mean
that's just unheard of if we're going
with influence in the community combined
with the animation and a bit of context
there's little doubt that demon slayer
takes the crown
2020
so demon slayer fever was in full swing
in 2020 and it capitalizes on the
momentum by releasing the infinity train
movie that caps off with one of the most
emotional battles in the series rengoku
vs akaza
[Applause]
now normally i would have been tempted
to pen this as a winner candidate
outright if not for the serious clause i
had then again even if it's not for such
clause this fight narrowly loses out to
another theatrical ufo table production
2020 also saw the grand finale of the
heavens feel movie and with it comes the
winner of 2020s fight of the year shiro
and ryder vs saber alter at this point
we're being desensitized to spectacular
fight choreography and effect you can
blame ufo table for that fights of this
quality have become so normalized now
but this one deserves a special mention
for how it finally put shiro and ryder's
strategy against sabre's sheer unmatched
power as seen in the previous movies we
also get to see ryder go all out which
is a treat because the poor servant has
been a glorified jobber in other routes
on the side of tv anime we have the
attention catching glipe near fight that
allowed the show to start off with some
momentum for such a niche title fgo also
ended with a theomath fight and a
barrage of noble phantasms that
shattered my expectations for a mobile
game adaptation if there's one thing
that god of high school is really really
good for it's just a showcase of fights
heck the running joke is that this
series is just fight after fight after
fight and while i lean towards agreeing
with that at least the guys behind the
production committee did the fight
pretty competently chinese anime fights
like the often featured fog kill fights
in the hitori noshita ones also debuted
here more on those on my old video that
you can access up there
overall 2020 has been a great year for
fights despite the delays and other
real-life circumstances that should have
hampered production
2021
we've finally reached the present
congratulations there's quite a lot to
be said for 2021 so let's get some of
the honorable mentions out of the way
after showcasing its worth through a lot
of epic battles and hype moments black
clover goes out with a banger of a final
arc the fight that led to that arc
arsenal and the army versus dante and
it's every bit as cool as fans made it
out to be naruto and sasuke also team up
again and this time in a far less
successful battle against g-game however
this got the shonen community busting
again and i find it funny yet sad that
one of the only times boruto seems to
gain this amount of traction are when
the legacy characters are involved in a
big way i also gave vv the nod for
action anime of the year and i can say
that the whole diva versus hugo segment
does deserve a mention gintama ended
this year with gintama the final movie
it gave us kintoki vs utsuro another
amazing fight with a lot of emotional
weight man i'm gonna miss that series so
much
once i look at the year however i think
that i can safely give the crown to
hanami versus yuji and todo
move over ufo table mafa is ready to
step up to the plate and while it felt
difficult to choose amongst the numerous
masterfully crafted fights in jiu jitsu
kaizen i gave this fight the win
why it feels like the one with the most
hype behind it sure gojo broke the
internet to a lesser extent yeah nanami
and megumi both got to show off their
cool stuff even novara got to show off
her sadistic and dangerous sight however
if you look at context and what the
fights mean for the protagonist seeing
the master student tandem of yuji and
toto team up against the big boss is
such a joy
and that's a wrap it's been a decade of
epic anime fights and the cool thing
about this is that i barely touch the
tip of the iceberg i'm sure that lost in
the shuffle are countless hidden gems
and i'd ask you to introduce me to some
of them so how did you find this video
if you liked it hit the like button and
tell me in the comment section so that i
know whether you're fond of the new
direction i'm taking with these lists if
you're up for some monetary support be
sure to check out my patreon and
memberships thank you for watching this
list it's been a fun ride through memory
lane with you all i hope to see you next
time and i wish you a good day